hey guys dr. Berg here in this short video I'm
going to talk about pH the big question is how
do you know if you're too alkaline or too acid
and that's a good question because even when
people tell you you're too acid and you need to
alkalize it it's not necessarily always the fact
because what what body fluid are you talking
about I mean are you talking about the blood
which normally should be slightly alkaline or
you talk about the stomach which is extremely
acid or the urine that should be slightly acid
or the bile that should be alkaline or the large
bowel that should be acid so you always want
to determine what pH you talking about what
I'm talking about is the blood pH the blood page
should normally be slightly alkaline and if it's
just a little bit too excessively alkaline you
can get all these symptoms right here if it's a
little less than that it could still be on the
up and side but just not as alkaline you can be
more acidic so that's basically all the symptoms
that can occur if your blood pH is too far this
way versus too far this way okay so let's just
talk about symptoms you can use symptoms versus
rather than like a pH thing for your saliva or
your urine because how you going to check your
blood you know it's really an expensive test and
by the time you take the blood out of your body
it oxidizes with the oxygen and the pH shifts
so it's really hard to detect that so I like
to use symptoms first okay so if you're too acid
you could have possibly chest pain palpitations
because it affects the the electrolyte mix
headaches anxiety muscle weakness bone pain
joint pain and air hungry like like your can't
get enough air okay and then alkaline would be
excessively aqua be much muscle twitches like
tetany that little twitch right here or on the
arm allergies muscle spasms muscle cramps muscle
weakness why because the calcium is all locked up
you're going to calcium build up to dehydration
because you need this the electrolytes need to be
hydrated correctly that the pH is off to alkaline
you can't mobilize electrolytes muscle pain and
also difficulty breathing this would this be
more of a hyperventilation just it's just a
difficulty with breathing but sometimes it's it's
difficult because you might have some of these
in some of some of these so there's one quick
way to determine what way you are all you have
to do is drink some apple cider vinegar like two
tablespoons and some water with a straw drink that
and see if some of these issues clear up and you
feel better and if you do that means that you're
too alkaline or let's assume that you're too acid
take some calcium citrate or calcium magnesium and
see if you don't feel better it's a quick way
to determine what pH you are so that's a that's
one way that you can do it so it's you don't
necessarily have to do an expensive test and
some people I just give them a little calcium
magnesium or lactate and boom like half these
things clear right up but the ultimate thing to
do is to get on the right eating plan and your
body will bring your pH to the correct balance now
as we're talking about symptoms and causes I have
a quiz down below in the description box that's
104 questions go ahead and take this quiz and I
will send you a report to tell you what's going
on with your body all right thanks for watching